made with real fruit or vegetables this
is a super common friend of label claim
on kids snacks but also on adults Foods
alike let's turn that package around so
food ingredients on a label are listed
in order by weight so the ingredients
that make up the majority of a product
are at the top and the ones of minute
amounts are down at the bottom we can
see that vegetables aren't up here
they're down here after flour oil sugar
spices seasonings Etc and this is why I
often say that a piece of broccoli could
fart on a cracker and we could say that
it's made with real vegetables now I'm
not sharing this to fear Monger I don't
think there's anything wrong with veggie
straws or veggie chips like they're
super delicious
but choose them because they're
delicious and you like them not just
because they contain real vegetables I
would we rather see someone choose a
plain cracker that they really really
like and serve it with real vegetables
or another nutritious ingredient